what kind of meat is that oh this yeah
frog meat oh nice
[Laughter]
this might be squirrel actually
that looks like someone took a frog and
put it in a panini press and just like
either that I just ran it over yeah or
that and just peeled it out of the tire
tread
um bro yeah
happy birthday thank you you feel like
[ __ ] I feel like ass too yeah yeah I
feel like ass I'm a little bit sick
under the weather that did not can't
really breathe for some reason that did
not
foreign
and actually keep your eyes closed okay
please be a moose
please be alive moose uh uh Happy
Birthday to me happy birthday to me
happy birthday dear
happy birthday is this a big laundry
ironing board yeah this is this a big
laundry is this a big laundry yeah it's
a giant ironing board dude you shouldn't
have yeah open it
it's kind of hard to open I got a piece
of my hands here put the mic down keep
talking I gotta put the mic down yeah
so I've presented Cody a gift that
may or may not be a surfboard
oh you [ __ ]
he's doing ASMR with the with the gift
wrap
we just lost like 10 000 audio listeners
what do you ASMR that's true oh new gift
foreign
Christmas morning ASMR hey hey hey get
your hands off
breakfast first
you ungrateful piece of [ __ ]
I actually stand
ing Ryan's face right now I didn't know
there we go there we go because I'm
waiting for it to break a little no
[Laughter]
no
[Laughter]
damn I've never had this like switch
from how excited I've I was to like how
[ __ ] disappointed that was the
craziest
ah
open that for the it's a long board it's
a surfboard for everyone listening and
it's a longboard which is what I wanted
but look what's on it
[Laughter]
hey man you should look at the back
you should tear that off and look at the
back
dude
no you don't want to use this no
it's on the bottom
you don't want to use this
you don't like it
you don't like it I'm this is the worst
gift I've ever done
you don't like it
you hate it
yes I do you don't like it
[Laughter]
I know
you can you can put your toe right on
that one I feel like my feet will be
right here yeah this would just be
looking right out of your balls yeah
yeah
hey nice turn
happy birthday dude sincerely man from
the bottom of my heart [ __ ]
you wanted a longboard so bad that's
even funnier like I can't even like just
have this in my garage yeah you can
that's true actually I'm gonna put this
above the bed yeah no put the back side
above the bed
and Kelsey can be like what the [ __ ]
Cody
yeah it's a nice ass board too
I'm so conflicted it's like half of me
just wants to destroy this
yeah yeah like burn it or
no I mean destroyed in a barrel oh yeah
you should
yeah I mean you you have to that's just
content bro let's even make this by hand
you shaped it yeah I shaped it I did
everything
did everything I made those faces too
it's a sick board
thanks
from the dims on this [ __ ] nine
two uh-huh
76 liters oh this is a big boy
Try Me Out Try It Out
take a ride on me I mean try me out try
it out I don't want to [ __ ] the board up
that that one right there yeah this is
the one anytime hey
thank you man of course if if you ever
bail you ever cook slam right as you go
you'll just see 50 me being like
happy birthday that is so funny
he's so upset he wanted I know he was so
hyped he's so pumped no that's that
initial I know surface board yeah you
can I'm gonna have to like just cover it
in wax
no just head to toe just a layer this
thick dude just give me a Go-Kart with
your face on the front you drop on the
nose
my [ __ ] will look like skin people would
be like who does he race for I'm gonna
they're gonna be like what the I'm gonna
paddle by what the [ __ ] is this guy it's
so much bigger than all my other boards
it's like immediately anyone goes into
my garage that's where their eyes gonna
go I should be that should better be on
your story dude I expect honey I'm home
[Laughter]
damn dude
have you beat a funny okay let me tell
you how this gift came to fruition yeah
Ryan goes Chloe's birthday is coming you
wanna get him anything kind of crazy
come on yeah by the way what do you
think
oh
well I'm surprised admissions Lily
accident do I put the shirt on and I was
like oh my God it's perfect who made
that this is a general admission like
one of my favorite Brands dude I bought
this like three weeks ago I didn't even
think that they pay you to say it like
that too yeah one of my favorite Brands
located on Abby Kinney actually there's
a there's a it's a pop-up shop on
nebuchane actually uh no but he isn't
that funny but anyway sorry keep going
Lobster by submission wow
like a surfboard or something what I
said was like yeah can you get one with
my face all over it
and Ryan's like up he was like okay like
do you want to give him a cheap boards
like no get him a [ __ ] nice one
take it out of my cut make it make it
nice how much was this oh it's like a
thousand dollars
[ __ ] you
I wanted this to be such an ethical
dilemma it really is I wanted to get you
a [ __ ] like a Hemi or or like a
Ferrari of a surfboard but it's just me
all over it's hilarious because I also
can't sell it
yeah
like I'm stuck with it or I actually
have to destroy it yeah
like it's crazy and then well in my side
I asked Cody what can I search for would
you really want like that you don't have
yet it's like I really want a longboard
and Ryan's just dying laughing because
he's like
okay yeah you want the biggest biggest
perfect type of surfboard
they sent me a picture of it
I was crying
I'm like that [ __ ] is taller than a
garage door
good luck foreign
man it's so funny just take it out with
Marcus and everybody yeah I'm gonna have
to take it out one time for sure just
actually I'll film it yeah just and then
we'll watch it on the on the podcast
yeah yeah that would be really funny
actually getting footage of like me
actually on a wave
and like sitting on it because when you
sit on a longboard right like the front
pops up yeah
I'm out here just riding noelle's face
it's my podcast co-host
people on the beach what the [ __ ] is
that
my podcast that's your boyfriend nice
That's my boy